I need nothing and you need to learn how
to figure that out when your expectation
of others is zero when you do not rely
on a single person emotionally or
financially when you start creating the
game inside your own head and allowing
yourself to have incredible incredible
happiness and peace and your reliance on
yourself when you create a structure a
game a blueprint of framework all my
favourite words when you create that
world where you are accountable for
everything your happiness and everybody
else's happiness around you and when you
start building the momentum of that
framework and you start taking on that
responsibility for not just yourself and
just your parents and your brother and
sister but then your closest friends and
then your closest acquaintances and then
acquaintances and then business partners
and then people that consume your
content and then the ambition to have
everybody consume it and take on that
responsibility and when you ask and
leave nothing of any of them when you
create a gained a world where you no
longer put the responsibility on your
parents or older brother your mentor
society a country a flag a race of creed
when you take on phone mother [ __ ]
responsibility for yourself in yourself
you require nothing of anybody else and
you create a program that allows you to
be at that peace accountability to the
fullest
responsibility for everybody else -
happiness in your selflessness your
selfishness for your selflessness your
ambition to do that for others you
create that program and you become that
accountable when you understand that it
is on you TV and nobody owes you
anything well then you can get really
really quiet it gets really really quiet
and then you can start really achieving
something please my friends please ask
nothing of nobody please expect zero
please create a situation that you are
not at the mercy of the machine or of
that parent please eat and create that
short-term pain learn and enjoy that
short-term pain
respect and adore that humility and that
accountability and that practicality
and let it be the foundation of your
life explain you
aren't at the mercy of others